hey guys I'm really excited because I
just want to refill my liquid nitrogen
do and this time i ordered 30 liters but
they filled it up to the top
that means i got five liters for free
let's go put it to good use
today is the day where we answer the
question what does liquid nitrogen do
inside of a 6-foot water balloon
let's go find find out
oh man that's a lot heavier
than it was last time
now you might be wondering how dangerous
is liquid nitrogen and honestly it is
really really dangerous but not if you
respect the boundaries and work very
very quickly
got my wife here to help me
what do you think about all these crazy
experiments they want to know
they're always too much
it's boiled down a little bit so we're
just going to top it up so we get as
much liquid nitrogen in there as
possible and then I think it's time to
load it up
all right now this is where it gets real
I've already put a zip tie around the
neck here on the ideas stretch this over
the thermos turn this upside down and
dump everything in there and then tie it
off
we'll see if we can make that work
ohh, that's already getting crispy and can
see starting to blow up that's cool
zip tie just came off, that's not good. and that
neck is completely frozen
oh well, I'll have to warm that up I can't get
it off now, that things completely frozen
taking the gloves off
check it out, the bottom of this balloon
it's like a turtle shell, oh there it
goes there it goes. look how hard this is
almost like a helmet
luckily I brought backup ok so we
figured the reason I didn't work last
time has all the nitrogen froze the
rubber before we had a chance to tie off
so this time we're going to try some
kind of an insulating barrier we've got
water bottles styrofoam liners finals
maybe even a paper cup they were just
stick down the neck I'm gonna have my
wife try pouring into the balloon
present rather the whole thing upside
down we'll see if that makes a
difference
check out how big the neck of this
balloon is i think it's massive
so we should be able to stick this paper
in there no problem
that's actually a perfect fit
ok got all in there but the neck is
pretty well frozen off I think we might be in business
self-inflating balloons
now at this point the balloon is getting big enough i don't
really want to play with the too much in
case I pop it accidentally
I'm just going to let the nitrogen keep
expanding on its own until it runs out a liquid
let's just see how big it gets
look we sprung a leak
it's still expanding and it's still
blowing up but nitrogen is leaking out
faster we can contain it
is that a hole, right there, or is it just gas?
Oh my goodness
ok so update we're on Balloon number three
and these things aren't cheap, these are thirty
dollars each
we got a little duct tape so that the
zip tie doesn't rip into the rubber I
think that may have been one of the
problems we had from last time
till now I don't know that's a good
thing well and this is the neck again
okay we'll get this thing walmed up and tie it on
alright guys I think we're in business
we were this far and that's the hardest
part I think you look at the grass down
here
Crispy
Did that go in your face?
no, it was just rubber just hitting me in the eye
check that out though that is awesome
ok guys remember safety is important
and for some reason I wasn't wearing my
glasses and my eye definitely felt it
that rubber smack me right in the eye
ball and that hurt a lot
all right so here's the difference this
time we got duct tape around here
instead of the zip tie
we do have a zip tie under there but
it's like protected by duct tape so
there shouldn't be any sharp edges to
make this thing go off
now we're gonna get this off the grass
and go put on the trampoline because
there's a lot less chance the trampoline
is going to accidentally puncture it
like the grass did
ok guys this time glasses on for safety
Wow
I literally felt a concussion hit my
chest broom just like that, it was awesome
there you have it guys, it only took a
hundred dollars worth of liquid nitrogen
and a hundred and twenty dollars worth
of these 6-foot water balloons but we
got there in the end, we can now answer
the question what does liquid nitrogen
do to a 6-foot water balloon
thanks for joining me for this
experiment i'll be looking for you guys
in the next video I'll see you there
hey guys I just had to give credit where
credit's due big thanks to my friends
who came out last minute help me film
this today I'm Mark Wilson on the drone
pilot with skycams media
we're tom and Robin film's and we make
high-quality videos of awesome people
taking all their stuff with their links
in the description will see you next
time